this is I think now 92 I can't remember
a year or something like 92 and I had
been friends with OJ Simpson a bit since
79 we were on a flight together my first
wife ingred who you remember ingred and
I were on a flight with him going to
Albuquerque he was doing a movie I was
doing a TV movie and we socialized while
there with Nicole lovely lady they
seemed to be very happy couple and then
years later he got divorced I never knew
why at that point and I was with him at
the China Club in New York commiserating
about my marriage my first marriage had
ended and where I went wrong he said
yeah I really messed up with Nicole I
said I no I did too with Eng he said no
I really messed up with Nicole yeah I
heard you the first time this is before
she was murdered but she was at this
point putting uh Polaroids in a safe
deposit box of her beaten up and when
the cops would come for the eighth time
they go you've been here seven times
before this when are you going to do
something about it it was a spousal
abuse case of the worst sort nobody
people who were close to him like I
wasn't that close to him but I was
friends with him I had no idea and then
then it happened it was terrible I I
knew what he meant then by I really
messed up with Nicole he had been doing
it a while so you knew like off the bat
when he was charged and everything
before even the court case and every all
the stuff came out that you were pretty
positive that he had I knew after about
24 to 48 hours at first I'm going Say It
Ain't So because I didn't know about the
safe deposit box and the Polaroids and
the baseball bat where the cops came I
didn't know any of that that came out
very soon and then I went oh my God and
then very quick you learn there's 38
pieces of physical evidence 38 most
people were on death row for one drop of
blood one hair one fiber he had 38
different pieces of physical evidence so
was like within 48 hours oh he
killed her and he killed poor Ron
Goldman
too have you seen him
since I'm sorry how have you seen him
since OJ no I have I have not seen him
since I was shooting at uh a golf course
somewhere and I learned he was on the on
the link somewhere and I just kind of
stay in my dressing room I didn't want
to run into I don't know what what
you're good with the murderers prior to
the actual crime like exactly not so
much not so much
afterwards